[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and it's time to mambo
number five as we go over the umbrella
academy season three the new series has
just dropped on netflix and throughout
this we'll be talking about what happens
at the end the clues that we have for
its true meaning and also our theories
on where things will be heading in the
future
spoiler alert
the season ends with the universe very
much being reset and we see that har
greaves has not only taken over the
world but he's also managed to bring
abigail back to life if we time travel
back to the 10th episode in season 1
then it actually explains a lot of the
big reveals at the end of this one in it
we caught the man whose moniker is the
monocle on his homeworld as he said
goodbye to his wife sadly his world is
dying and he had decided to travel to
earth in order to quote unquote save us
he opened up a jar full of strange
glowing orbs that he then released and
for a long time it's been theorized that
these were absorbed into the mothers who
gave birth to the superpowered children
we get this confirmed at the beginning
of the season with them flying into
ben's mother as she rides a train this
somewhat plays into the post-credits
scene featuring a version of ben which
we'll talk more about later on in this
video now come the end of the season we
see these orbs being absorbed in order
to power up hargreaves's machine so that
he can start things all over again thus
i think that his plan the entire time
was to create beings that ended up
taking these orbs inside of them so they
could mature and grow to the point that
the universe could be reset and he could
start everything over again this could
explain why he ended his own life in the
first season as potentially he wanted to
bring them all together and have them
unite so that the machine could be
powered it's also possible that the
world we see in episode 10 of the first
season is actually an alternate timeline
in which earth was destroyed and this is
why he has to go back and save it big
theory time every time your time on that
one but let me know below exactly what
you think is happening also hit the
thumbs up button yeah give me a wrench
now in season 2 we watched as he ended
up becoming heavily involved in the
space race and the comics flash him out
as a nobel prize winning olympic gold
medalist there are other theories that
we'll talk about later on but hog reeves
wife was clearly very important to him
in the season we learn a bit more about
luther's mission and discover that he
was also guarding her body on the moon
which had been put in stasis similar to
nora freeze we're going to be breaking
down why this is and also looking at the
comics for some clues on where things
could be going now the series is loosely
based on the third volume in the
umbrella academy run titled hotel
oblivion not only does this debut the
sparrow academy but it also features the
titular location however the
similarities pretty much end there and
outside of the sparrow members the works
are completely different for example in
the source material the hotel was an
interdimensional prison that housed all
of their villains whereas here it's
hiding something much more powerful now
when we last left our intrepid umbrella
academy they had saved the world again
but in doing so they altered events in
the past
and made it so that they were completely
new members of the team these were known
as the sparrow academy who as i
mentioned also featured in the comics
the graphic novel completely did away
with the time travel and it simply had
mother taking vonia to meet the group
these had been secretly picked by
hargreaves to act as a backup and they
shut up at the end of volume 3 in order
to save the day now in the show there's
a number of reasons why things changed
due to dallas he was disgusted by the
group and he ended up picking other
members with ben only being there
because he never actually met him due to
his death this is also american holland
who we discover inherited victor's
powers for years he waited patiently for
the umbrellas to return and upon his
mother sissy's death he ended up feeling
them unable to control his powers he
accidentally killed them all except for
benz who again he never met now little
disclaimer elliot page of course
transitioned in real life and when
discussing his character i'll just be
using the name victor they reuse a lot
of clips from the second season to add
new context to the character becoming
who he truly is and its handle pretty
well in my opinion now in this timeline
marcus ben fay alfonso sloan jamie and
christopher became the sparrow academy
who were formed to stop a mysterious
threat called project oblivion netflix
series have shown us recently that you
can't trust number one like you can't
trust no one and though this like no
zero zero one i know this is the case
initially with marcus and ben they do
come around i'm sorry for that now they
are more successful mainly due to the
fact they didn't split up as the
umbrellas had several tragedies happen
five went missing ben died and this led
to the group fracturing right here
they're a much more stable unit they
also have their father on medication
which sedates him and this puts a stop
to him being the manipulative monocle
that he was in the comics he still has
plans for them to go on a suicide
mission which they don't want to happen
hence them filling him with pills now
this season sees both the umbrellas and
sparrows having to deal with yet another
apocalypse making that three in three
seasons oh [ __ ] here we go again
this is because their arrival also
brings about the appearance of a black
hole-esque object known as a kugelblitz
which it's believed is brought out due
to the paradox that the umbrellas have
created due to their mothers being
killed before they were born they very
much set up the grandfather paradox
which five explains during episode two
why don't you explain this to me like
i'm five
this is a well established theoretical
discussion in science that ponders if
one would be able to time travel in
order to kill their grandfather because
in doing so it would mean they were
never born thus they'd never be able to
go back and kill him in the first place
so it's more like a big ball of wibbly
wobbly
tiny whimey
stuff
and the commission we saw last season
attempted to ensure that this never
happened well it did due to them being
defeated with the umbrellas technically
not existing this creates the google
blitz and it starts to fire out a wave
that slowly destroys reality in the
comics this was the result of a
combination of the people in the hotel
oblivion prison causing chaos in the
city and the villain terminal used this
to build his strength the season is very
much about how the past can come back to
haunt you and nowhere is this more
apparent than in the arrival of holland
when we last saw him he was levitating a
foreboding sparrow at the end of season
two but now he's all grown up now making
it so that the umbrellas never existed
also meant that allison never had a
daughter which sends her into a deep
spiral in what's one of the most
complicated and well-acted subplots this
season all these issues eventually build
up and it means that the world slowly
starts to look like an incursion in the
multiverse of madness now as their
members are taken out one by one the
sparrows and umbrellas put their
differences to the side and try to get
to the bottom of what's going on they
also have a face-off in episode 1 which
juxtaposes what happens in the comics in
the source material the face-off
happened in the final issue of volume 3
with them easily outmatching the sloppy
umbrella academy not much is known about
them in the source material but they
will be explored more in the upcoming
volume titled sparrow academy after this
they will lick their wounds and head to
the hotel obsidian which in the show is
like a merge of shadow marmont combined
with a cecil hotel there are also
several references to the shining namely
in the carpet pattern used and this
pretty much becomes the mainstay
location for the series the pandemic
obviously had a big effect on the show
and there were definitely aspects of it
limited by what was happening in the
world obsidian was built by hulk reefs
as a cover for the portal to another
dimension and this is watched over by
trypophobia triggering guardians here
lyla arrives with her and diego's
apparent sun stan who you may recognize
as being ashtray from euphoria this
entire thing was a test to see if diego
would be a good dad and stay with her
which he does in the end as he's really
a big softy like your uncle kevin
spoilers now we discover stan was
actually a kid she found in berlin after
being set free by the commission and he
ends up getting wiped out by the
kugelblitz later on in the series as for
the commission it turns out that their
founder was actually an older version of
five who warns his younger self not to
stop the apocalypse joke time what you
call old five
ninety
also i don't know if this is an older
version of five or if the younger five
is older but moving on now we also learn
what happened to pogo in this universe
and discover that he ended up joining a
biker gang after leaving hog reeves
employment this spiker gang was also in
the comics named the mothers of agony
but they were connected to klaus's story
instead now pogo ended up training with
them but he fell out with hargreaves
over the oblivion mission which we learn
will kill all those that take part in it
interestingly in the opening of episode
6 we see that the group are forced to
fight over a bell and these bells end up
playing into the finale as being what
the group must stand on hargreaves tells
them that this legend of the seven bells
comes from myths and he plays koi over
the whole thing even though he's
subliminally planting the idea in their
heads that this is how they save
everyone rise in the comics the hotel
was akin to arkham asylum or the raft as
mentioned earlier it absorbs life in
order to power the machine to reset the
universe reginald has tried several
times to charge up the device and we see
a mixture of soldiers sent into the
pocket dimension that all get wiped out
by the guardians this is why hargreaves
decided to train the children so that
they'd be strong enough to fight back
pogo didn't want to be a part of it
though and neither did the sparrows
because they knew that it would lead to
their deaths this led to the sparrows
drugging him so that it couldn't happen
and this hargreaves was unable to put
his plan in motion now he just sits
about watching tj hooker until klaus
comes along and gets him off the drugs
he of course was addicted himself and he
sees saving him and finally getting some
quality time and somewhat redemptive
this opens up a full storyline where
klaus is manipulated once more to get
not only the umbrellas back together but
to get hog greaves back into the family
so that he can use them to enact his
plan elsewhere allison learns of
harlan's attack on their mothers and she
ends up killing him she also joins
forces with hargreaves later on due to
him providing a way to bring back her
daughter this alternate timeline at the
end seemingly gives everyone their
hearts desires as not only does she come
back but so does rey who she of course
only knew in the 60s again lots of time
you why me wibbly wobbly stuff but there
is even potential that this may be a
false reality or heaven due to everyone
getting what they want even though a
number of paradoxes would be created
alongside this we also have the romance
of lutheran sloan and slowly over the
season they start to fall in love as
reality dwindles away they decide to get
married to spend the rest of their lives
together next four hours just
see you chump
now there's a big well a small party and
after it hog reeves makes a pact with
allison and he then later kills luther
this was designed to bring them all
together to stop the destruction which
again calls back to the season one
saying that they only see each other at
weddings and funerals klaus is killed in
the final wave and the remaining heroes
end up fighting the guardians standing
on the sigils they defeat the final one
but then the truth about the machine is
revealed alison realizes that it'll kill
her family and thus she ends up
murdering hargreaves stopping his plan
whether she still goes to press the
button and though victor initially tries
to stop her he ends up trusting that
it's the right thing to do not like
there was anything else to do anyway and
this changes the entire timeline now
interestingly they travel there on an
elevator which could be a nod of the
comics namely the ones that they use to
travel into the hotel this new universe
seems completely idyllic and rather than
being how it should really be it's
exactly how they want it to be rey
appears to be the father of claire
instead of alison's ex-husband and the
heroes no longer have their powers this
also means that luther's body is back to
normal and that he's no longer fused
with ape dna everyone heard her killed
also appears to be alive with diego
getting his fingers back however sloane
is missing and though luther goes
looking for her we're left wondering
whether she exists here now the heroes
find the plaque with a brass model of
hargreaves's head that was donated on
the day the children were meant to be
born it's unlikely that he ever went
looking for them because he didn't need
to release the orbs due to his wife
abigail still being alive again it's an
example of the grandfather paradox and
it's going to be interesting to see
whether this causes another kugelblitz
now it also seems that he's taking over
with all the skyscrapers bearing his
name and it's important to note that
they look far more advanced than what
the city used to be like now i have seen
theories that alison might be in her own
separate timeline this is because she
didn't arrive in the elevator with the
rest of the group and her arm still has
a bandage on it i think this is probably
just down to the fact that she was the
one who pressed the button and perhaps
reginald wanted to keep the things that
were part of his body in this universe
he may have had plans to mod it like
what he did with luther and even if he
didn't carry this out he could have
wished to build a way to retain parts of
himself if it ever came to that however
this could also be because she didn't
get drained like the other members did
they all stood on the sigils whereas she
didn't so in this reality she could end
up still possessing her powers this
could mean allison might potentially use
them as ways to bring back the abilities
of the other family members and i hit a
rumor that you subscribe to the channel
now not having his powers will allow
number five to actually grow up aidan
gallagher is 18 now so it's gonna be a
bit difficult going forward for him to
constantly keep playing a 13 year old so
they might have done this as a way to
let him each up a bit we did see
something similar at the end of eternals
and it makes sense looking at what
things are going on behind the scenes
going forward i think that the cast of
characters will realize that their lives
are all missing something and that
though this seems like an ideal world
it's actually not they might end up
having to take on their father once more
and potentially they could end up
restoring the universe back to how it
was in the first season it's difficult
to use the source material to guess
where things are gonna go as it's not
really in line with the work at this
point and if you've read the graphic
novels then you'll know the show is only
very loosely based on them from here we
then go to the post-credits scene and we
have what i believe is the original ben
seemingly living his life in seoul south
korea with this being an ideal timeline
and him never being part of the
umbrellas it would make sense that he
never died as a kid though his spirit
left in peace in season 2 there was
another version of him created for the
third season whereas the other children
were stopped from existing by holland
therefore we likely have two bends
namely the sparrow timeline version and
the original one however him being born
and being on the same train shows that
his mother still had him makes you
wonder how this happened as his sudden
pregnancy was down to the orbs behind
him we also see sparks that look like
them flashing up and though this could
just be off the train tracks it could
also potentially be the powers if we're
reaching which we often are now i also
scan the qr code in this scene and as
many of you know we get early access to
shows like this
nothing was coming up for weeks so i was
actually expecting it to be a massive
secret like the announcement of the
release date for volume 4 or even a new
season however it's just a link to
pogo's tattoo shop where you can get
designs bit of a waste of time so pogo
on that
so going forward i'd love to have us
learn that this is an alternate world
where everything worked out however this
might show that there are doppelgangers
in this universe and the group could
come to realize that they don't belong
there this could make them want to reset
the universe once more as they're stuck
in a timeline where they're not welcome
who knows they might even try and start
the apocalypse this time which i think
would be a great twist our grieve seems
like he could be a tyrant in this
reality and whereas the other seasons
were clearly about resurrecting his wife
this could be about killing her they are
of course both aliens and the pair might
rule over the planet like tyrants lots
of possibilities and as for my thoughts
on the series i think this was probably
my second favorite one season 2 is still
the top for me but this was brilliant
and it's so good being back with the
family they like this season all have
their bad points but overall they're
such a fun group to hang around with
that it's difficult not to have a blast
whether it's the opening dance number or
just the situation they find themselves
in i had a lot of fun even though i feel
the series did fall apart a bit towards
the end obviously the pandemic massively
affected this as well whereas in the
past we'd get lots of jumping around
locations through not only time but the
city this one becomes a bit stationary
still though i enjoyed what we got and
the character development numerous
twists and reveals that all build up
nicely on what's come before
kind of wild to me that both this and
the boys have been better than all the
other comic book shows by bigger studios
and i think they could learn a thing or
two from them in the end umbrella
academy season 3 was great and it gets
an 8 out of 10. i'd of course love to
hear your thoughts so make sure you
comment below and let me know we're in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of everything everywhere
all at once on the 15th of july and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the season we picked the victors a on
the 15 and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now say that's you
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
obi-wan which will be linked on screen
right now we went over the full season
finale and talked about the easter eggs
in it things you missed and also gave
our thoughts on it definitely go head
over there right after this and without
the way thanks for sitting through this
i've been paul see you next time take
care peace